hello everyone and welcome to another
interesting game from round seven of the
Gibraltar trade wise chess festival here
we have eleven our union with the white
pieces against Nigel short unfortunately
I couldn't find any interviews with the
players after the game maybe they just
haven't uploaded any maybe there were
some if you've got the live coverage of
the event and if any of you have access
to such an interview do share in the
comments and I will add it in the
description later and I'm sure you'll
enjoy this game as its it's a classic
Iranian game so the solely just see it
Oregon has the white pieces and he opens
with C for the English opening we had e5
Knight to c3 and d6 this is the
so-called reversed Sicilian variation to
the English opening Knight to f3
we have f5 and g3 Knight to c6 and d4
here our onion kind of kind of taunts
nigel to push efore but this isn't
something you want to do here probably
better is something like Knight to f6
and after white pushes d5 Knight to e7
and I'm sure this this would be a lot
preferable than to what nigel actually
played after this d4 he did go for e4
and now attacking the knight and here we
have d5 by Aaron and this was the idea
Knight to e5 now here Knight captures D
captures and it seems like short has a
very nice central pawn structure here
and maybe he could you know put it put a
lot of pressure on Oregon's King side
but here our engine immediately plays g4
and what do you do here you definitely
don't want to capture this only messes
up your pawn structure and the white
would be very happy playing a position
like this
so after g4 your options are Queen to h4
or probably Bishop to c5 or what Nigel
played in the game so we have Bishop to
c5 and now Queen to b3 Knight to f6
and Queen to b5 check as this solves a
lot of troubles for our onion as this
Knight was attacking the g4 pawn and now
he gives check to the black King and
also attacks the Bishop on c5 so only
move that
actually is useful for black here is
Knight to d7 stopping check and
protecting the Bishop on c5 and here we
have H for not allowing this Queen to
enter the h4 square you still don't want
to capture on g4 this really achieves
nothing after capturing bishop comes to
g5 it's it's an excellent position for
white so after this h4 move we have a
six kicking the Queen back Queen b3 and
now a very active move by short III here
are n captures Bishop captures Bishop
captures and F captures and it seems
that he managed to ruin our engine spawn
structure here a bit but it's not all
that big of a deal we had F captures on
g4 now and Knight to e4 Knight back to
f6
we have Bishop to g2 and short castles
here we have c5 with some ideas of maybe
sorry pushing d6 soaking to h8 getting
out of the pen and here we have a
queenside castle and here you probably
want to go with Queen to e7 the rook to
b8 and start pushing on the Queen side
but Bishop to f5 was played here and
this isn't the most precise move this is
probably the move that allowed Ariane to
take momentum here f5 does seem like an
excellent move as it you know places the
bishop on this beautiful diagonal but he
immediately gets Knights to g3 and now
the bishop really can't stay there you
have to admit it was a mistake probably
go back to c8 and create some sort of
another plan but as it often is the case
in chess you don't want to admit your
move with a mistake so that's probably
what happened here nigel goes bishop to
g6 and here h5 is played and now again
you have some troubles to consider for
example if you move the bishop bishop to
e8 you get the immediate h6 after you
move h capture some g6 skin captures and
here you go d6 and with two very active
rooks
an active queen a beautiful Bishop this
Knight is ready to jump to f5 to h5 it's
simply a much better position for white
so after this h5 move Nigel actually
played Knight captures on h5 seems like
he decided to sacrifice a piece we have
Knight captures by Orion and now rook to
f2 attacking the bishop on g2 and here
are Ian goes Bishop to f1 defending the
bishop and Queen to f8 we have night -
g3 and if you look at this position you
don't I mean by playing Queen to f8
there is this c5 pawn that's attacked
but you can't really defend it if you
try something like this you lose the
piece back we just simply capture the
bishop and after rook captures you
capture on f1 now this rook isn't
defending the bishop anymore so you have
to give up the c5 pawn Aragon plays
Knight back to g3 Queen captures on c5
this is with check and now Queen to c3
are in an offers a trade of Queens as he
is up a piece nigel declines this with
Queen to e7 and we have E for now
Queen to g5 we have King to be one
getting out of the check and Queen to f4
King to a-1 and now rook to f8 now
there's this very nice battery and the F
file but it doesn't seem like it will be
enough against an extra piece rock to g1
defending the knight on g3 one more time
we are roped to f7 and now comes a three
attacking the Queen Queen to g5 and now
go to c4 threatening some discoveries
with d6 we have roof to d7 and now Queen
to b4 we have b5 now and here a
beautiful move by Aragon Knight to f5
what Knight to a5 this rook is no longer
protecting the f8 square so you can't
capture the bishop if you capture it
It's Made in one Queen f8 this is
checkmate
so after this Knight to f5 move short
plate h5 making some room for Ace King
but now comes Queen to e1 and now
although the bishop is still attacked
this rook
not escape if you captured Bishop are
not simply captures the rook rook the f3
was played but now comes Bishop to e2
again with an attack on the rook rook to
h3 and now Bishop to f1 and if you try
to save the rook with rook to f3 you get
to Bishop to g2 again winning the rook
if you try Rock - H - you get Queen to
g3
again winning the rook so here short
doesn't even try to save the rook
anymore he plays Bishop captures an f5
Bishop captures rook on h3 and here
Bishop captures on e4 Bishop back to g2
and Bishop captures rook captures and h4
now and if you look at the position now
short is down a whole rook but he does
have to seems like he does have two very
strong extra passed pawns but
unfortunately here in this position are
in place
Queen to b4 and when I say unfortunately
I mean unfortunately for short not
unfortunately for Arnhem after this
Queen to b4 move Nigel short resigned
the game as there is simply no way to
take advantage of the to pass pawns
this Jeep on is now attacked twice the
thread is simply capture it after you
play something like g3 pushing it rook
comes to h1 and there is nothing you can
do the H point the H point is now
attacked twice and there are no back
rank tactics for black here there is
nothing here you can simply maybe play
King g8 but then Queen captures and you
don't want to trade this Queen since
you're done done a whole rook you can
try something like Queen to f6 maybe to
improve your pawn structure but there
really is nothing for black here Queen
h8 check King moves now rook captures
and now you've lost all of your extra
pawns and our Ruby one is coming White
was simply captured on g7 or do whatever
he wants so after this Queen to b4 move
Knight off short resign the game and a
very nice victory for level Narnian like
I said in his style he always does some
very nice maneuvers with those h4g 4
moves
so I do hope you enjoyed it and I didn't
really check the standing so far I think
there was like five people fighting for
first place yesterday so I think it's
like Nakamura is still in the top Aragon
is in the talk
I saw Gregorio purring David Howell and
but after today's all after all today's
games finish tomorrow I will have a
better idea of the standings and I will
present them to you as such so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here I think all for
watching and thank you all for joining
my test stream today morning on Twitch
it was very nice I still have a lot of
things to figure out on Twitch but thank
you all who joined played some games and
helped out so thank you all and I will
see you soon